All right, Lee. How you doing, Lee?
>> Hello, Bishop TV Jake and Benny Hinn.
Hi. I miss you guys. What are you guys
up to besides money and [__] What do
you guys want?
>> Yeah. See, so I can I have the mute. How
do I How do I get rid of this idiot?
>> You don't see the You don't like You
can't click the top part of his name.
>> I got it right there.
>> All right.
>> So, only when they connect I can kick
these kick these guys.
>> Yeah,
>> because Chevy D. What's up, man? School,
man. Brother, man, what going on?
man. Walaykum salam man from the
Messiah. You like that?
>> I like it.
>> So Jesus is God, man. What's up? What
you think?
>> No. Well, Jesus can never be God because
Jesus is the creation from God.
>> Really?
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> I don't see nothing. I don't see nothing
saying that Jesus is a creation from
God.
>> Where you get that from? Where did you
get that from?
>> You for real?
>> Can you show us where you get that from?
>> Yeah. Tell me. Show me it.
>> No, we asking you to show us where
you're getting it from. that he's
created.
>> Oh, no. That that is just natural common
sense in natural common sense. And that
is that that is in the Quran.
>> No, it's not.
>> Yeah.
>> Where in the Quran does it say Jesus
creator?
>> Let's never say I never say Jesus is the
creator. And I say God is the creator
that sent Jesus.
>> Yeah. Jesus is a creator too in the in
the Quran. You didn't know that.
>> Hey man, thanks for thanks for coming,
>> bro. Hell Lord.
>> I don't think it's going to work.
>> But you were able to I like that you
were able to engage with him. That's
This is This is so cool, guys.
>> Yeah. No, this is a lot better for sure.
>> Daniel, how you doing?
>> How you doing, bro?
>> Good.
>> Pretty good, man. Pretty good. You
disagree.
>> I don't disagree. I agree.
>> All right. This is only for people who
disagree, my brother. Love you, man. I
can't be any more clear, can I? Guys, do
not come up if you agree with us. Only
come up if you disagree. What's up, man?
You're on stage.
>> Hey, man. Uh, how are you? You hear me?
>> Pretty good. Yes, I can hear you nice
and clear.
>> Yeah. So I I disagree and um I would
start by let's just define what's what's
what do we mean by God like we have to
at least bottom line
>> the creator of all things
>> right uh so when when Jesus says my
father is greater than what he's
referring to here
>> he's referring to the fact the father is
greater in position because it's greater
to be in heaven than on earth so he's
talking about a localized position or
localized presence
>> well u so there's there's
So many things you can actually describe
that Jesus has a lower position not just
in term of like position but also in
term of knowledge. For example, Jesus
didn't know the hour,
>> right?
>> Yes, he knew the hour. That word know in
Greek is oid day. That word just can
mean to reveal or make known as it's
used in Deuteronomy 13:3 and the
Septuagent also in first Corinthians as
well by Paul.
>> Are you sure?
>> Yes. Yahweh literally uses the same word
ode in Deuteronomy 13:3 in the
Septuagent to say when he talks to the
people and says, "I tested you to know
whether or not you love me with all your
heart." Yahweh obviously knew their
heart, but he was testing it to reveal
it. That's what the word also means to
reveal.
>> Yeah. But but but it's it's very clear.
Someone asked him, "Do you know the
hour?" He said, "Not not the angels nor
the son."
>> So what was my answer just now? Yeah,
your your answer is like he's in in
Greek it doesn't. So are you saying this
is like a mis m
>> I'm saying what was my answer?
>> I just want to make sure you're
understanding what I'm saying. What was
my answer? Just
>> I don't understand. You say in the
original original man manuscript in the
basically the Greek it says what we
saying is it's he he know the hour
basically.
>> What I said was the original language
the word for no was o day. That word no.
Even in the English language, the word
know means multiple things. Kind of like
the word see. If I tell you I see what
you mean, it don't mean I got physical
eyes that I'm seeing what you're saying.
It just means I have some sort of
knowledge. The same word the word know
can mean knowledge or it can mean to
reveal.
>> Yeah. But but what's your point? Just
because I I'm I'm not able to grasp what
your what's I'm still not
>> my point is when he's saying he doesn't
know the hour, he's saying that he's not
the one that reveals it. He's not
talking about knowledge. He's not
talking about knowledge. What he's
talking about?
>> He's talking about revelation. Revealing
the hour to the people.
>> Revealing to the hour to the people.
>> Mhm.
>> That's right.
>> Because that does doesn't make sense for
me. Could you explain for me?
>> So he's not he's not saying,
>> brother, he's not saying that he does
not have cognitive knowledge of the day
and the hour. He has that cognitive
knowledge. He has that information.
>> It's just not for him to make it known
to people. That's for the father to do
only.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. No worries. I It
doesn't make sense for me, but it's not
like I'm not here to just uh just keep
like tickling on this point. My next
point is when when Jesus uh was in the
cross and I mean when he was uh when he
was when he's saying my god, my god, why
you left me? Yeah. I I know many people
refer uh he was like referring to the
>> to the song, right?
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. But but again, even if he
referring to the Psalms, does that mean
he's contradicting the the purpose of
like the like Jesus dying in the in the
the cross for to basically to for the
sin of other people? Is it like not
>> how would that be how would that be
contradictory what he's saying on the
cross
>> by just saying that by just saying it
right even if it's like refering the
psalm
>> even if you why do you refer to such
song to such words in such position or
in such situation
>> because he's in despair he's he's in
despair he's he's like this is what the
not only the psalms but also Isaiah
talks about how he would be a man
acquainted with grief and sorrows right
so Um he's he feels all of that. He's a
real feelings that he feels. He's not
just acting. He feels the he feels the
despair of the moment. And really, if
you read the psalm, it's really about
how long must I still keep going through
this? How long must uh are you from
saving me? That's that's what the psalm
is. If you read it, it says, "My God, my
God, why have you forsaken me? Why are
you so far from saving me?" you know.
So, but then he goes on to glorify God
still and says despite this you are I'm
vindicated in you and you know um in in
you I trust and you know so on and so
forth but it no it it in detail lays out
the crucifixion event you know so
>> okay yeah um I don't want to actually go
to the to the basic because I think it's
it's very clear there's a very clear
question here Jesus is God I'm not going
to go into the defininity thank you guys
for giving me the chance
Okay. Take care of yourself, man.
>> Take care, man.
>> All right. So, that's that. Let me
actually make sure we switch the Okay,
there we go.
>> You drop me.
>> Oh, yeah. I got you. I got you. I'll
drop you. Got you. I got you. Let me uh
I'm still learning how to do this to
myself. All right. Have a good day, man.
All right. All right. Our uh Zack Zack
Adam, how you doing, man?
>> How you doing? You all right?
>> I'm pretty good. I'm pretty good.
>> Excellent. Uh just a question. If Jesus
is God, would he know his name?
>> Would he know his name? Yes.
>> Okay. What's his name?
>> His name is Jesus.
>> Oh, it's not Yahweh.
>> What?
>> What? Why?
>> Bro, Jesus the son has multiple names.
Who told you he only has one name?
>> Yeah. We're not talking about multiple
names. His name. We're not talking about
multiple names. I'm talking about God's
name. If Jesus is God,
>> God has more than one name.
>> No. God has more than one name. Yeah.
Yeah. Would he know his name? Obviously,
you don't know his name. Do you know
God's name?
>> Multiple names. Yahweh, Jehovah.
>> Okay. So, would Jesus know the name
Yahweh? Jehovah.
>> Yes.
>> Where did he say that in the Gospels?
>> Well, seeing that the Gospels are and
Yahweh is a Hebrew word, it's obviously
not going to be there.
>> Where? Where? Jesus spoke Hebrew,
Aramaic, and Greek.
>> But the New Testament wasn't written in
Hebrew, so it's not going to be there.
>> Oh, it's not going to be there.
>> Why? Why does he have to say the word
Yahweh?
>> No, as I said to you, there's not a why
he has to say it. Does he know his own
name?
>> We already answered that. Now, we
already answered that. So, now you're
insisting that unless Jesus Hold on.
Excuse me. I'm talking, brother.
>> You said now now you're saying unless
Jesus says the name Yahweh, unless he
says it out of his own mouth, then that
would indicate that he doesn't know the
name Yahweh.
>> You're stunning me. I didn't say that. I
said if he is God, if he is God, then he
would know his name.
>> All right. So, it looks like you're just
repeating that. Take take care, man. Go
ahead and watch the clip back and see if
>> arguing from silence, obviously.
Anyways, but you know,
>> Charles, welcome on the stage, man.
What's up? How y'all doing? Pretty good,
man. You disagree?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Like life, bro.
>> Is life still in your room? Check on
that, man.
>> Life life went to uh Life went to go get
some food
>> and he just hopped on. Yeah, that's
crazy. All right. Yeah. So, what's
what's uh what's what's your um what's
your argument against this, man? Off
topic.
>> So, you said Jesus is God. Like, you
mean like like power? Like, what do you
mean by God?
>> He's the most high God, bro.
>> Uh no, he's not. So, so we Okay. So, I
mean, let's just find some common ground
here. So, we both can agree that like,
you know, that he died for somebody.
>> He died for everyone to believe.
>> I don't believe that, but you do. That's
okay.
>> What do you believe? that he died for I
mean the nation of Israel.
>> Oh, we can talk about we could talk
about that next. You think you're an
Israelite?
>> I don't I don't think I'm an Israelite.
>> You know you're an Israelite, huh?
>> No. I mean, do
>> you claim to be Do you claim to be an
Israelite or No, man.
>> No, I don't. I mean, it's hard to it's
hard to make that it's hard to make that
claim. I mean, we don't have like
verifiable evidence, but I mean, it's a
it's a I mean, there's some strong
evidence.
>> So, you think that Jesus came only to
die for for Israel?
>> That's what it says. So, so let me ask
you this question. We'll we'll get there
next though. We'll get there next. So,
yeah, he died for someone.
>> So, let me ask you a question. So, when
he died,
>> if if he's the most high God, when he
died, who was who was like who was
ruling in heaven? Would he would
>> He's still ruling when God
>> He's still ruling in death.
>> That's That's insane.
>> Do you think that death do you think
death means you cease to exist?
>> No. We know we know your soul has a like
has an intern type of
>> Exactly. So I'm not saying that I'm
saying just because he experiences death
doesn't mean that he ceased to exist and
stops ruling. Uh like God God is not
ruling.
>> But would he wouldn't he be doing but
wouldn't he be doing dual
responsibilities because wasn't he
>> God has God has all the responsib
responsibilities.
>> I know but I'm saying like in that in
that instance he's doing dual respon I
mean you're giving one person two
different things. We're saying that God
does God has multiple things he takes
cares of. So,
>> okay. Well, we we we both agree on that.
But what I'm saying is
>> so Jesus Jesus dying for our sins and
also still sustaining the universe by
the word of his power.
>> There's nothing wrong with that. No
problem.
>> That's insane. That's insane that y'all
believe that.
>> It's It's almost as insane as
>> because it doesn't make sense.
>> It's It's almost Charles It's almost as
insane as saying that God created
everything out of nothing. Huh. Like
that's just insane to say, isn't it?
While at the same time sustaining that
thing that he created,
>> so that it doesn't get destroyed.
>> Sustaining. So sustaining. So for three
days, so for 3 days like what was who
was controlling you know,
>> do you believe do you believe that God
can do more do multiple things at once?
You think he can multitask?
>> I believe that in that in that instance
when he's dying on the cross in your
from your perspective because the
trinity the trinity is absolutely false.
Like what do you cuz then we're not
we're really talking about
>> you're not answering the question. Do
you believe that God can multitask?
>> I I've already answered that question so
we're we're we're redundant.
>> Yes or no?
>> It's a yes or no.
>> I've already answered it in my in my
speech before.
>> Yeah. Maybe maybe we don't understand.
Maybe we're not. Can you just make it
clear for us and say yes or no?
>> He can do multiple things. However, two
things can be true at once. We haven't
even discussed. I'm sorry.
>> He could do these multiple things at the
same time.
>> He's omniresent. Like quit asking silly
questions. What I'm saying is not making
silly arguments. Can he do these things?
>> I'm not making silly arguments. I'm just
being I'm just being for real. Like,
>> brother, Charles, I'm I'm giving you
I've been patient. I'm giving you some
time to be able to be here. Be direct.
Be honest. If you're going to waste my
time, I'm going to move on.
>> Can God
at the same time at once? Yes or no?
>> He absolutely can. Can I Can I make my
point? Hold on.
>> Can I make my point?
>> Finally answering the question. So Jesus
dying on on the cross and still
sustaining the universe is not
illogical. It's not a contradiction.
Correct.
>> It no that is correct. It is a
contradiction because you guys are
>> correct and it is a contradiction. Nick
I'm saying like I'm not saying he
sustained life. I'm saying according to
your belief he did. But I'm because we
this is a deeper conversation. You guys
like
>> what's the contradiction? What's the
contradiction? Well, let me ask you this
question. Um, do you believe that he was
immaculately concept like concept?
>> It has nothing to do with what I just
asked you.
>> No, it does. It does. No, it does. It
does. As I as your question go ahead,
ask your question again. My bad.
>> That's what I'm saying. Do you believe?
>> Go ahead and ask your question for real.
>> My bad, bro. Go ahead. All right, man.
Usually, it's the Tik Tok guests that
are just like tarded re,
>> but man, the YouTube guest has been
>> sound different today. Uh, stop
laughing, wife. You need to be nice.
>> Hello.
>> How you doing?
>> I'm good.
>> This is Muhammad on Tik Tok.
>> Yes, it's Muhammad.
>> All right.
>> My question is, you said Jesus died for
us our sins and on the cross, right?
>> Well, first we're talking about Jesus
being God. That's that's what we're
talking about.
>> Okay. Jesus being God.
>> Mhm. So if Jesus was God, why would he
say the true and only God is the father?
Why would he say that?
>> That's creating confusion.
>> I'm not going to lie. He actually That's
a good point.
>> He might have cut us there.
>> You haven't heard that argument yet,
Nick?
>> This might be a first for me, bro. The
only God, bro, if if God's only God's a
father, how the freak is a son guy?
>> That's Yeah, it can't be God.
>> No, but listen. Uh so when in that verse
he's he's uh making a declaration of
nature not personhood right so when he's
saying the father is the only true god
he's declaring the only true nature of
god to the father he's not declaring
that the father is the only person with
that nature though
>> with that nature. So if it is two natur
two people that have the same nature
right I mean three
>> three three persons that have the same
nature. Yeah.
>> Okay. Three persons that makes them one
having that one being of being God.
>> Yeah. The fact that they have the same
act, right? The same the an absolutely
identical nature, etc.
>> Okay. Okay. So, they are three different
persons in one go. God of being God,
right?
>> They're one God. Yeah.
>> Okay. Why do why the separation though
of personalities? Why is that that
separation?
>> Well, first of all, it's not a
separation. And it's a distinction. Uh
second of all, it's not different
personalities, it's different persons.
The distinction is going to be because a
father is going to necessarily have an
offspring, which is so the son. So they
got to be different in some way. If
one's the father of one, they got to be
different.
>> Okay. So do does Jesus have a mother? Uh
does Jesus have have a mother when he
was just the god being? Did he have a
mother?
>> What do you mean he's just the god? I
think I think he means before he took on
flesh. I think
>> he did not have a mother before he took
on flesh. No.
>> So why why the need to have a mother
when he's human? Why couldn't he just
trans transform into one or something?
>> Because he's not living a full human
life that way. To live a full human
life, it's going to be through an
incarnation. So he's considered to be
the new atom. Okay. And
>> okay, why the need to be a human? Like
that's the need because by taking on the
human nature, he elevates the human
nature up to him. So when he takes on
the human nature, then the human race
gains a union with him. So now since
we've gained a union with God, we're
able to actually reach him and he
rebuilds the bridge that Adam and Eve
once broke by sinning.
>> Okay. That's a need though. If you need
to be a human to do something, that's a
need.
>> It's a need for us. It's not a need for
him.
>> It is a need for him. You said he had to
become a human
>> for us.
>> He had to for us, not for himself. God
could have never became human and
>> his life,
>> right? Yeah. But we wouldn't have been
able to be unified with him if he didn't
do that. That's the point. It's a need
for us, not for him.
>> That's the truth.
>> A need for us.
>> And what did we do? What do we What did
we do to for him to to to elevate us?
What did we do?
>> We didn't do nothing. That's what he
did.
>> We didn't deserve it, bro.
>> Yeah. He took on flesh.
>> This the whole point. We didn't do
anything to deserve God coming down and
elevating us and rising us up, imputing
his righteousness unto us, giving us his
righteousness and justifying us.
>> What we deserve was his wrath and
destruction. What what we No, we didn't.
What we deserve is his wrath and
destruction.
>> Um but what he does because he loved us
is that he came down and lived the life
we should have lived. take on the flesh
to represent mankind because we couldn't
represent ourselves. So, he did.
>> Okay. Okay. So, we did have
righteousness. That's where you got it
wrong from.
>> You're righteous
>> because Adam was was was
uh
>> Adam wasn't righteous. He sinned.
Literally sinned.
>> Yeah. He sinned, but God made him on his
own image. What is the image of God?
What is the image of God?
>> You're you're a Muslim, right?
>> Yes, I am a Muslim. What is the image?
If you if you sin, are you righteous?
>> No, you are not.
>> So, did Adam sin?
>> Adam did sin.
>> Then he wasn't righteous.
>> He was created He was created that way.
>> He was created what way?
>> He did God God made him with his own
image, right?
>> Yeah. What when you say he was created
that way? He was created what way? To
sin.
>> Okay. Is God is does God
>> Dude, you're not you're not dealing with
Oh my goodness. Follow the conversation,
please. Somebody
>> My bad. My bad. My bad. When you say God
made him that way, it sounded like you
said that in response to him sinning.
>> Are you saying that Allah made Adam to
sin?
>> He he made Adam Yes, I guess.
>> So, so Allah made Adam unrighteous.
>> Wait a minute. He did make him
righteous, but he also give him the the
ability to do wrong, too. So, he can
distinguish what is wrong and right. So
there's a difference between making
someone with the ability to do wrong and
making someone to do wrong. So did Allah
create Adam with the ability to do wrong
or did he make him to do wrong?
>> The ability to do wrong?
>> Got it. So he didn't he didn't make him
for the purpose of doing wrong.
>> No. No.
>> Then you're going against Muhammad cuz
he taught that Allah made Adam to do
wrong.
>> Adam Adam uh as you guys say is is made
of God's image. What is God? God is all
righteousness.
>> Yeah, but you're you're missing what I
just said.
>> Okay, that's why I said we need
>> what I just said, bro. Allah created
Adam for the purpose of doing wrong.
>> Of doing wrong.
>> Yes. Yes, I know that. Yes.
>> You so not with the just the ability to
do wrong. He made him, he created him to
do wrong for the purpose of doing wrong.
For the purpose of sinning.
>> Not just that. It's just
>> Oh, not just that.
>> No, no. He he made him that way. But
>> he knows Adam Adam was was created on
his image. He will reflect and think in
every action and try to do good.
>> That's the whole test.
>> So to be humankind,
>> so so to be clear with this, you're okay
with Allah who's supposed to be he's
supposed to be all good, right? Is Allah
all good or no?
>> Yes, he's all good.
>> He's all good. But this in this all good
and most loving God would create someone
for the purpose of sinning.
>> So uh uh the ability to do wrong and
right.
>> Okay.
>> The ability
>> I feel like I was pretty clear on what I
on on the distinction that I said and I
feel like you understood it and then
we're kind of going back.
>> No, no, no, no, no. I I I did. Uh
>> do you do you understand the
distinction?
>> Yes, I I do understand the distinction.
>> Okay. So I'm not talking about creating
him with the ability to do wrong. I'm
saying that
>> he was created.
>> Would it would it be wrong if Allah
created someone for the purpose of
sinning?
>> For the purpose of sinning. Just for
sinning. Uh
no.
>> Got it.
>> No.
>> So Allah can create someone to sin. Like
he can create them to s for the purpose
of sinning
>> and then and that's perfectly fine.
>> He he wouldn't do that. But yeah,
>> why wouldn't he? He
>> why wouldn't he do it? He He has the
ability to, but he didn't.
>> Why wouldn't he do that? You said he
wouldn't do it. Why wouldn't he?
>> Because God is all just. He wouldn't
just do that and and and not give him a
lifeline or whatever.
>> Very good. So, it would be in it would
be unjust of Allah to create someone for
the purpose of sinning, right? That
would be unjust of him to do so. He
could do it, but it would be unjust if
he did that. Is that right? I mean by
unjust is creating someone to sin and
then putting the hellfire and saying
>> yeah and then punishing them for the sin
he made them commit. He created them to
commit. That would be unjust, right?
>> Well, yes, that would be unjust.
>> All right. Well, that's what we have
with Adam. That's what Muhammad taught
and said that Allah did.
>> No, Allah didn't.
>> Watch this.
>> Allah No. Allah made him to uh have
created him with the ability to do right
and wrong.
>> You see the You see my screen on the
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Is it too small? Can you see it?
>> Yeah. Okay, good. I'll make it big just
to say just in case we can make that a
little bit bigger. All right, cool.
>> So, hold on. Let me actually I gotta do
it like this actually. Okay, so I'll
just read it off. It says narrated Abu
Herrera, the prophet said, so Muhammad
speaking saying, Adam and Moses argued
with each other. Moses said to Adam,
"Oh, Adam, you are the father. You are
our father who disappointed us and
turned us out of paradise." Then Adam
said to Moses, said to him, "Oh, Moses,
Allah favored you with his talk, and he
wrote the Torah for you with his own
hand. Do you blame me?" Now, here's the
important part. You ready? Do you blame
me for an action which Allah had written
in my fate
before my creation? So, Adam confuted
Moses. He defeated him. He when they
were arguing, he won the argument. And
and so, Adam confuted Moses. the prophet
added repeating the statement three
times. So we see here that Adam says to
Moses, "It's not my fault. Me disobeying
Allah, eating the fruit when he told me
not to, that's not my fault. Allah wrote
for me."
Yeah, I know that's not his fault.
>> So it's Allah It's Allah's fault that he
did that, right?
>> It's not Allah's fault, but Allah made
it that way.
>> So whose fault is it? Is it Adam's fault
for eating the fruit, or is it Allah's
fault for writing that in his fate to
eat the fruit? So, so uh did did Allah
know that El was going to rebel before
Adam?
>> This has nothing to do with El. This has
to do with Adam.
>> That that that has to do with El too. If
you understand the text,
>> well, I understand the text. What What
does it have to do? Could Could Adam
have told Ell, "No, I'm not going to eat
the fruit."
>> Yes.
>> Okay. He could have even if Allah
>> Even if Allah wrote in his fate
before he was created that he was going
to eat the fruit, Adam could have still
not eaten the fruit.
>> But a human can forget. He forgot the
promise. That's why he ate the
>> It's not the promise. It's not about
that. Could Adam have not eaten the
fruit even though Allah wrote this in
his fate? Could Adam have chosen not to?
>> No.
>> Exactly. Okay. So, whose fault is it
that Adam ate the fruit? Is it Adam's
fault or is it Allah's fault?
>> I don't like to use the word fault,
>> but that's what it is. You know, let's
say this. Let's let's use responsib
who's let's say accountable. Who's
accountable?
>> If it's fake, you cannot change it,
right?
>> Correct.
>> That's the point.
>> Okay. It cannot be changed. You got to
you got to ask your question. You you
got to say why did Allah do that? Why?
>> I don't I don't care why, brother. I
don't I don't I don't care why Allah
did.
>> You don't want the answer then.
>> No, I don't that's not my question. You
don't want the answer.
>> No, that's not my question. If if I was
asking you why did Allah do this? Then
that would be you know you giving me an
answer would be answering my question. I
didn't ask that. My question is whose
fault is it? Who's accountable for
Adam's sin? Is it Adam himself or is it
Allah?
>> Is is is Allah Allah riding his fate
already?
>> So it's Allah's fault, right?
>> I wouldn't say fault.
>> Can we say responsible that Allah is
responsible for it?
>> Yeah. Uh yes.
>> Okay. So we'll say that Allah is
responsible for it. Not we won't use the
word fault. We'll use responsible. So
Allah is the one responsible for Adam's
sin. And then guess what happens as a
result of Adam's sin? What happens? He
gets punished. He gets turned out of
paradise. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So Allah punished Adam. He created him
to do a particular sin. He created him
for the purpose of this sin. It's one of
the reasons why he created him to do
this and then punishes Adam for doing
what he made him do. That's unjust. You
got to understand why though. Why did he
do that? That's not unjust. You don't
know the
>> You're the one that said it was unjust
earlier. That's the point.
>> I know that is unjust. But you don't
know. You don't know that.
>> You agree. It's a Amen.
>> Amen. Agree that.
>> I don't agree. I I don't agree cuz Allah
is trying to tell you something about
why did he do that? So why so so now
you're about to go into justifying why
Allah committed this unjust action,
right?
>> It is not it's not unjust if you
understand why.
>> But you you said that this is
>> if you understand the reason I I didn't
say Allah is unjust for that. I never
said that. I said your god is I said
your definition of god is unjust.
>> No. No Muhammad that's not what you
said. Let's see see life. I don't know
if you're listening. This is why I said
have my YouTube tab up
>> so when I rewind when they say cuz they
say things
>> and then they say no. I never said that
and then I have to rewind for them.
>> I I never said I never said my God is
unjust. I said your your definition
>> you never said you never said your God
is unjust. You never said that my
definition of God is unjust. You never
said either of that. What happened was
is I asked you if God were to create
someone to sin and then punish them for
that sin he created them for, would that
be unjust? And you said yes. Remember?
>> Yes, that would be unjust. But
>> okay, so here we have Adam who was
created to sin and then got punished for
that sin that Allah made him do.
>> Okay. So, uh, why don't you ask the
question, why did Allah do that?
>> Because I don't care why Allah was
unjust here. I only care that he was
unjust.
>> It's not unjust when you know why.
That's what you don't understand. Why
did he do that? The why is more
important.
>> So, you know why he did it?
>> Yeah, I know.
>> You know why?
>> I do know why.
>> You know why Allah was unjust. Tell us
why Allah was unjust here.
>> I didn't say Allah. Okay, whatever. So
when when Adam when Adam before Adam was
created right Adam said uh before I was
created Allah he was already wridden in
my fate. Okay. Did Allah know that El
was going to is is going to rebel
against the the humankind? Did Allah
know that before El came to heaven?
>> Yep.
>> He did know that. Okay. So when when he
came what did he do? He hate he hated
Adam. So Allah Allah knew everything in
in in advance and made everything happen
that way. So Adam Okay. So Adam can see
his enemy, mortal enemy. So that that's
why wait stop
>> as your enemy and your family.
>> Stop. Stop. Stop. You're So I just want
to be clear with you. You're saying that
the reason why Allah created Adam to sin
and then punished him for the sin he
made him do is so that he can know El
his enemy.
>> So he can fight his enemy. Yes.
>> So he can fight his enemy. Adam Could
Adam have fought his enemy without Allah
creating Adam to sin?
>> Without creating Adam to sin.
>> Mhm. If I could could Adam have fought
against Els and known his enemy that was
Eliss without Allah putting in his fate
that to to sin against him
>> uh to sin against him. So
>> let me let me let me break it down
again. Okay.
>> Could Adam have known that El was his
enemy and fought against Eling
the fruit?
>> Without eating the fruit? Yes, he could.
>> Okay.
>> Exactly. So Allah making Adam eat the
fruit is irrelevant to him having
knowledge that El is his enemy. It looks
like the only enemy of Adam here is
Allah, bro. Not El.
>> Wait, wait. What is the What? What? So
if if Adam had had no uh no sin, nothing
at all or only good and all of that,
right? Only good, no test, eaves,
whatever he wants. What is his purpose?
What do you believe? All creatures have
purpose.
>> Well, why did Allah create him? Why did
Allah Allah make See, the Quran doesn't
answer that for you. But
>> wait, wait. Do you need to have Wait, do
you need to have Do you need to have sin
to have purpose?
>> Do you need to have sin to have purpose?
>> Uh uh you need to have evil evil what or
good to have a purpose.
>> So there needs to be evil to have
purpose.
>> Yes. That's what Allah is.
>> Do wait, do babies have a purpose?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. What evil do babies that are
unalived, what evil do they do?
>> They do not have no evil cuz they don't
know.
>> So, but how do they have a purpose then?
You said you need evil for a purpose.
>> So, uh babies dying. What? Uh it's just
uh it's just uh what is it called? A a a
a
what is it called? A a a uh
>> what is it? It's just a demonstration.
It's just a demonstration of of God is
here.
>> Look, bro, do do the babies themselves
have
>> No, babies, bro. That's what I said.
>> Mama, you you can definitely I'm going
to go ahead and let somebody else up,
but I I I appreciate the uh the
conversation, bro. You definitely gave
gave it a shot. I appreciate you were
the first one that gave us a real
conversation, so I appreciate you, man.
>> I appreciate you guys, too.
>> Yep. You can come back another day, man,
and we can talk some more. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> All right. God bless you, bro.
>> You, too.